[Musik]
b
die hieraus linien der winkels musik
heute schon ist aber ein brockenhaus mit
wechselnder inszenierung mal ein büro
mal eine stube heute also eine boutique
und alles was es hier zu sehen gibt
könnte ich also kaufen aber brauche ich
dieses hübsche täschchen wirklich
natürlich nicht jedenfalls nicht um zu
überleben
aber es wäre natürlich das tüpfchen auf
dem i meiner garderobe und so ein
schnäppchen
gebt doch auch die laune wenn auch meist
nur kurzfristig frust ventil
persönlicher bedarf oder soziales
bedürfnis zum shoppen geht es viele
gründe
und die meisten davon sind total
rational seien
eigentlich haben wir noch genug ruhe
aber wir wollen immer mehr kaufen ist
eine luft kaufen ist ein ereignis kaufen
befriedigt an seine bedürfnisse in zwei
büchern hat sich der
kulturwissenschaftler wolfgang ullrich
mit dem thema konsum auseinandergesetzt
herr ulrich weiß warum viele so gerne
kaufen jahr wird er vielleicht waage und
unterhalten wollen oder ein wort ein
gutes gewissen verschaffen wollen oder
weil er bestimmte gefühle erleben wollen
weil er durch gute erinnerungen fliegen
wollen aber viele produkte sind heute
von vornherein schon so designt dass sie
viel mehr bieten wollen als nur die
erfüllung als gebraucht wert der
menschheit nicht als konsument buch
früher kauften die nur für unseren
grundbedarf seitdem hergestellt
konsumieren wir auch was er nicht
benötigen
luxusgüter waren früher den reichen
vorbehalten venedig verfügte zum
beispiel im fünfzehnten jahrhundert per
dekret nur der vater das weitertragen
und heute ich würde sagen in den
siebziger jahren begann das so richtig
massive cup sicher schon davor erste
ansätze etwas später ging es dann
vielleicht mehr darum dass man sich
selber definiert darüber dass man seine
eigene identität gehabt oder
pluralisierten reicher werden es
versuchen überall
der konsument wird umgang umworben und
verfügten
er kaufte eine fast schon suggeriert zum
beispiel einen überirdischen life 3 das
eintauchen in eine traumwelt
schreiben und solche impulse geben neues
zu schaffen
ich würde sagen die hauptantrieb feder
ist entweder ein interessanteres leben
zu führen oder ein besserer mensch zu
werden also letztlich noch mal das
eigene leben zu steigern durch die dinge
die man kauft und durch den man eben mit
jedem einkauf heutzutage auch entweder
einen bestimmten erlebniswert hatte eine
emotions wehrt sich verdrückt oder eben
andererseits man seine eigene rolle
seine identität schaffen und aufwerten
kann durch den kauf dieser produkte
hoffen wir also bessere menschen zu
werden durch die wahl beim kauf
demonstrieren wir zugehörigkeit
selbstbewusstsein individualität die
niederländischen flugplan iwf live und
alien bruch an
sie fotografieren seit 30 jahren
menschen verschiedener sozialer gruppen
bitten sie ihre individualität durch
kleidung auszudrücken
[Musik]
das ergebnis ist ein nicht ganz so
einzigartig wie der mensch sein wenn
peter nicht unterschiede im
kaufverhalten zeigen sich dagegen bei
männern und frauen sozial geschlecht
also dass man selber nennt gibt es
sicher unterschiede was auch damit zu
tun hat dass für frauenfeld konsums
erste und lange zeit das einzige war wo
sie überhaupt so etwas wie individuelle
auswahl tätigen konnten wo sie sich
profilieren konnten wo sie sondern auch
ihre art von geschmack bekunden und
auslesen konnten also frauen wussten so
tal auf frühe konsum kompetenzen
erwerben als männer
wenn männer einkaufen schauen sie sich
gern bei autosport topf oder elektronik
zubehör um die tätigen gern so genannte
wohnungskäufer doch es bleibt konsum und
er hat ein schlechtes war man auch das
gefühl hat vielleicht auch kardinal
wohlstandsgewinn wieder unseren wir uns
geht es gut auf kosten von anderen die
jetzt hier hunger leiden die unter ganz
schlechten bedingungen geben die
untergangsstimmung bedingungen diese
dinge weit hergestellt haben die wir
jetzt hier einfach mal so schnell
verwenden oder verschwenden
es gibt viele gründe warum ein
schlechtes gewissen haben kann
und trotzdem geraten viele immer wieder
in einen regelrechten shopping wahn kann
einkaufen krankhafte züge annehmen
natürlich haben viele menschen ohne
unrast weil ich weiß selber nicht wohl
in ihrer haut fühlen weil sie unerfüllt
unerlöst sind und dann hoffen dass ihn
jetzt irgendeine marke irgend ein tolles
produkt hier ein stück weit diese lösung
geben kann
es geht hier ein strom dass die soziale
sehnsucht ausgelebt wird mit dem aktes
kaufen kompensieren wir emotionale
defizite demonstrieren zugehörigkeit
geben und identität
wir kommunizieren indem wir kaufen
[Musik]